[Music]
that's bad right hey what the hell is
going on
what do you mean uncut
is that the end of the track
attention passengers keep your
belongings inside at all times
if you see a suspicious package please
tell the nearest mta employee
remain alert and good luck now
mino's found us
did you just say minos
no no no no
no no no no no i knew i should
have come back oh my god you guys have
played the game before
how do you think i got this huh they
left me in a goddamn submarine
and they increased the air pressure
until my eardrums burst
so that makes this what tournament of
champions
what the hell is that
[Music]
i just got shocked they electrified the
entire car
remain alert and good luck i found a bag
belong to any of you what's in it
it's a towel
okay let's find out where that handle
goes to
be careful about the pulse i'm seriously
doing this just give me that thing
the handle's metal so we need to be
careful that is an insulator
hey it worked
[Music]
it's one of those old subway token slats
i haven't seen one of these since i was
a kid
okay so we need tokens anyone see any
tokens anywhere
wait was that scientific all false
advertising must be pulled
yeah i i noticed something earlier
excuse me right here
this ad for hourglass fan says lose
yourself in the sand
yourself is missing an e check all the
signage see if there are any
misspellings
okay here c there's a c missing
statistic
okay c e um they're trying to spell
something out so maybe we pull the
corresponding handles with the missing
letters we hold the metal handles
is there anything else in the back the
lining is above but we can use this
pass them down a b c
d e
escape will turn the champions only in
[Music]
we cinemas lucky to get out of those
escape rooms alive i need to know that
the criminals who killed the four people
in front of me
are held accountable we're hiding in
plain sight in the middle of manhattan
we need to stop them i'm in
i know this is a lot to ask but thank
you for coming with me
hey what the hell is going on
you guys have played the game before so
what is this
like a tournament of champions
[Applause]
look we all know how this works we
solved the puzzles or we died
i was advertising most people this ad
yourself is missing an e
so maybe we pull the corresponding
handles with a missing letter
yes
[Music]
this is way bigger than last time you
got to try something right
yes there's a special reason each of us
survived
i can't feel physical pain just imagine
the kinds of puzzles they came up with
for me
take a picture will last longer get some
clues this looks just like the
lighthouse on the postcard
it's over i'm done running we can beat
them at their own game
what makes you think they're gonna let
you walk away free
[Music]
not again not ever
you need it we made it
okay i don't understand we're still in
the game
[Music]
you